hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seven days to die
with my good buddy Wade hey guys don't
you get the strangest feeling of deja vu
as if I've done that intro like 10,000
times already
what do you mean we've not done this
episode like 500,000 times yeah I know
we haven't I know we haven't otherwise
there would have been some evidence of
which we had done that but I mean it's
just a strange feeling in the back of my
balls like suckier what the back of my
balls
oh so I said listen where the confusion
was coming from I just you know I don't
know okay silly me so we're back into
this we've had it an extreme amount of
trouble and oddly enough I've said that
we've had an extreme amount of trouble
multiple times we keep having more
trouble but hopefully this is the one
this is this is the one because you're
watching this and if you're not then it
won't matter cuz we had more trouble so
I hope to god that you're all watching
this out there better be watching it
okay anyway know don't go into the
Iranian wasteland no way no oh no don't
do it there's so much to live for how
are those deer out there living in there
I don't know I wanted them you want eat
okay no just about Stanley whoa I knew
should go there who wouldn't go there I
mean come on
I don't alright anyway so that's enough
silliness for now we got to get straight
down to business wait um we are no
longer doing the 10-day cycle and as you
can see we're on a brand new 10-minute
cycle ah we are no longer on the old
server we are on a brand new server with
which we are trying to survive as best
we can and his fruit test will come at
night because that's where we've had all
the problems so far know what you're
talking about problems we seem to be
done pretty dead
I mean as as far as having to say the
same intro 18 times that's not where the
problems originate but I know I know
what you mean how did you get all the
way over there I coulda sworn that you
were all the way up here uh
started running cuz it's already noon
what is already new nose eyes 11:30
don't be digging around let me Oh but
I'm all that falling would hmm really
guys if my ears fixing the nation them
for fallen would I hear something that
sounds unpleasant a fun Africa jinx in
the nation
what is it a friend Mookie fans nation
don't know what that means
you should know you started it aku mover
the nation Hakuna Matata
um no no no no shut up shut up copyright
copyright ah uh uh for the beer nah blah
blah uh oh did you say hot marijuana no
I didn't say hot marijuana why would I
say that
oh I said flip moon I'm a plotter Oh for
the rest of the duration of your life
it doesn't mean you should be concerned
about your problems Oh cuz they do not
happen to coincide yeah I don't think
it's part of the song at all nothing at
all know what song our original song
that we just invented right now that you
and I work on on the Backstreet Boys
yeah cuz you know we are in lust really
singing where we are we I don't know
we're here we're just gathering up
materials as we go on our way and enough
[ __ ] your ever enough [ __ ] around
we really gotta buckle down and try to
survive I'm collecting his life up cuz
of a dear no I didn't put that is funny
is that your Woody Woodpecker laugh it
was unintentionally that yeah I'm not
sure that our our audience knows what
woody the woodpecker is is it this the
same stupid house we've been in every
time why yes it is how lovely
yeah come here dear I'm gonna put you in
the play which is dear boy yeah hell
yeah rap flip yeah yeah you got it I did
play oh come on
you made me think that I had it I know
oh why can't you give that to me hello
nurse but anyway yeah I'm just a quick
pull out there does our audience know
what woody the woodpecker is I mean I
know that's an older cartoon but they
don't really play that
anymore hahahahahaha whoa TC I don't
think that's woody the woodpecker uh-huh
uh-huh I want to get um hey Becky thank
you I got it this pistol sucks you know
what else sucks ha the economy ha what
that huh what oh this cheerleaders butts
hanging out this is it did you just get
a face full of a dead cheerleader but I
kind of did I had to pull stuff out of
it but there's nothing there
Wow good god what what it was it was
just like three zombies standing in the
doorway around was a Crawley guy after
you is there I'm out of ammo can you
kill them for me this rifle does not
have much bullet capacity I only got
three bullets left
all right fine I'm going to now screw
these guys ah my butt whoa you're that
shooter something in common no I wasn't
a cheerleader whose thumb big burly
zombie man it looked like you like all
kinds of people coming to visit I know
that was where oh shoot they were like
all in the doorway as soon as I rounded
the corner I don't know why I said that
word so profoundly but yeah I think one
cans by the way now and I don't know
what they do I'm betting they turn into
metal they don't turn into scrap metal
they don't know okay oh that's weird
yeah I don't know what to tell you about
that one here a puppy
you don't hear a puppy don't say the
word you find the ammo mother lode in
there yes I did rifle ammo actually oh
nice I can one-shot anything I found
cobwebs I guess it's been a while
where'd you find cobwebs Wade higher in
my chest
ah that doesn't make any sense
stare does not go back together the way
it river sitting some 800 numbers call
me should I answer it live on the air
you're what happened the last time you
did a phone call on the air no what
happened we were live-streaming oh yeah
my number got leaked out yeah yeah I
tell people about that now but the funny
story now I should I should have just
started answering calls right on the air
like I should have been should've
answered it's like somebody else and
confuse the crap out of everybody but
hey
you have reached mrs. Doubtfire or
something hello mrs. Doubtfire here
hello dear
hello Deary don't find the whipped cream
on my face
venomous I seen that movie that's the
only thing I remember of it with I'm
just punching the railing to get more
scrap metal
alright I'm breaking everything we hold
dear please do cuz you know how much I
don't cherish anything that we own what
happened if I punch this one
ya know that was my most cherished
prized thing whatever it was what our
sunroof yes
our sunroof not accepting that what I
feel like we know this house back and
forth by now
no why we've never been here people have
seen us be here liar that I'm having one
heck of a deja vu a deja vu there one
more time then hola Jay I mean actually
laughs are you bastard I the things you
do to me uh of it deja vu hoo hoo hoo
hoo
uh I don't have much scrap metal at all
this time hang on all the scrap metal
fell down I gotta go get it we do aw
did I mention that we're on 20-minute
days I can't remember what I've
mentioned before but I really because
we've gone through this so many times
but yeah we're on 20-minute days which
means that the day/night cycle is gonna
be long and hard huh ha ha like our work
life oh that's that what's that oh
you're up there breaking this yeah yeah
I'm still breaking uh things in the
fourth wall no the third wall floor
falls over there ha ha ha you know it
was our wit that gets us so many
foreigners humor yes it is it is our
pontification in Splore if occasion and
fam Dib dagi I'm punching a stop sign
what is this doggy doing wait whoa whoa
come here come here come here come here
come here here it's all right it's hold
anything do you see it I do that's the
name of Alex I got it oh I'd have no
bullets hang on I got a reload
come here puppy that's all is it again
oh yeah doggy what'd you do dear
ah boo ski I missed again I'll just let
it dance for a little bit longer
oh look a new Poochie hey must be right
uh-oh I didn't do it hang on shut up I
don't care if it's getting night I'm
trying to kill his Poochie damn it
it's bouncing around so much you don't
work you guys want to see really crappy
shooting here we go sob wait I got it
got a can of spam on him that's
interesting alright it's getting dark
but I'm gonna get just a little more
wood before we give me someone to fill
that strip a pole-dancing dog with their
meat what wait what
cuz had spam on it that is wrong this is
a kid-friendly show you douche sir since
when do you do anything kid-friendly do
you remember the remember the Save the
Children know we had some creepy thing
ha ha ha
it was that we're creepy do came from I
believe it was yeah creepy do if you
don't oh you blocked up the upstairs the
downstairs door is not blocked Oh coming
in don't block me don't block me don't
block me okay
didn't house your horde smartphone
network is good your horde of scrap
metal
not good I'm gonna 34 I am the winner
I'm amazing at this game good you get to
make all this stuff you're welcome
you're welcome
do we need anything for just scrap metal
do it can I turn it all into tin um I
don't think we need it right now unless
we want to make a CAD or something out
of it okay oh god 11 iron ingot which is
very weird that I can just mash scrap
metal into ingots but that's besides the
point
um you need so beta hahaha cuz it says
alpha is alpha you know I gotta admit
we're getting a lot more out of this
game than I thought we were like when I
first played it I was like it can't be
that good then surprisingly it's just
like what's that
it's paper through paper it yeah so you
can make the torches I'll try to make an
axe and stuff yes yes yes yes yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh-ho-ho-ho
burped I got 480 sticks breath okay
Feliz is what for a nanny sticks breath
I'm gonna make a shovel so you're gonna
say a shovel ton of torches would I make
a shovel ton I gave you all the stuff
tomato that is a sharpened stick what is
that there we go
oh man I got a shovel but it took a lot
of my iron ingots wait a minute oh no it
didn't nevermind I was mistaken
yeah I'm all make a pickaxe hey we're
gonna have ourselves good old time
all right well I've got this up
someone's already trying to break in are
they why we were trying to have a
peaceful quiet alone time night all
right I'm gonna make all of them I'm
gonna make the fire axe the uh-oh it
automatically place to stuff for the
fire about two hundred thirty six sticks
behind you thank you don't sit down
Wow as if I wouldn't let him stay get
your wood really wait yeah
uh-huh-huh-huh
oh you still funny I'm like going back
to some of your first Let's Plays humor
is that is that is that what you think
of me is that how low you think of me
actually you do what you say something
wasn't one of your big catchphrases
early on like something in the butt oh
yeah
oh man eva is this just like the
nostalgia episode where we go back and
look upon gasps oh yeah no that was like
whole chair up your butt nose like a
catchphrase for a long time man give it
can um people in the comments right
helmet whatever the oldest catchphrase
you know of me cuz there's been quite a
few that have like appeared throughout
this so uh give me your favorite
catchphrase whatever is all this is the
whole chair up your butt yeah up your
butt cuz I was from the compilation
earth house from my first name need to
play through that okay that was wait I
wanna go back in on April of 2012 you
know I used to think that you know I
hadn't been doing this that long but
then I remember I I have been doing this
way too long but I have some torches
please pretty oh yeah they're waiting a
B you got it boss hey by the way I don't
think I mentioned in this one I'm a lady
oh wait do you like my bazooms
your bazooms my bazooms do like someone
who serves anti are you in this way they
are good bazooms what was that noise
dude was my bazooms I'm sorry I they get
out of control hey but does not make hey
oh I need to calm my tits oh what's just
going downhill fast before the children
are for the children yeah for the
kingdom you know what take those thank
you you're welcome bazooms appreciate
your contribution
Wade you don't have anything to say that
I I have nothing to add to you
I never need to add to your bazooms
they're so good just the way they are
thank you wait it's a bad side of
someone wrong man huh all right I'm
gonna be digging I know I've done this
before
don't dig yourself into trouble
hahahahaha I'm sure if I did you
wouldn't dig it very much
ha ha ha and you wouldn't be able to dig
yourself out of that one ha ha ha
Oh am i I I always get myself into
trouble and I keep I'm digging my own
grave no I don't know no no these are
the kind of dirty jokes we should always
tell ha ha ha um yeah I got nothing else
I don't know good good we ran out Justin
something really bad leave it to beaver
like quote I don't even know what Leave
It to Beaver is what I don't know what
Leave It to Beaver yes you do you why
you should are you sure I do cuz I don't
think I do
like I what what is Leave It to Beaver
the Court did not cartoon that show from
like the 50's I'm not I'm not picking up
what you're putting down man I didn't
put anything down you're good I'm
sitting down there all right whew thank
you I got I got make some more wood blah
blah blah I just totally lost that's
gonna say this just evolved into like
mark this is Mark a bar humor Hey
huh oh boy ah cue squirrel
what else do I say I don't even know
what I say uh uh uh they're no help at
all all right we're all at a time for
those muscles thank you my god
yeah the strong are so handsome Mitchell
brave oh oh look at me we won't long for
Stan I don't know what this going on
over there but oh my god please stop
Hayley like there was a squid trying to
leave my mouth and I had a mustache you
know anyway Ari we're all out of time
for this 104 is the progress like we've
actually done quite a bit
albeit being very ridiculous while we're
doing it which i think means that we did
good right wait we did good
at least nothing went wrong we done good
okay so anyway thank you all so much for
watching thank you wait for joining me
as per you source remember all the
things I told you to put in the comments
forget all those if you wrote something
in the comments you're dead to me
yeah dear the next video
ah
God